hey how's it going guys welcome back
episode 3 here of design patterns and
today we're going to talk about an
abstract factory so strap in we're going
to dive right in and i'm going to first
explain a little bit of what an abstract
factory is now we already talked about
the factory pattern or method uh
factory's pattern is really broad it's
kind of like all these combined as
someone in the first video kind of
pointed out in the comments which was a
pretty accurate so yeah we kind of
covered the factory method on the first
one so i went ahead and renamed that one
to factory method so the abstract
factory it essentially does something
very similar except instead of like a
single factory where you just kind of
pump things out uh which what you have
is more like
several factories and then you have sort
of a top end controller or front-end
controller
and that one determines which factories
end up being used
that way you can kind of get varying
types so a common example we see in this
is something with furniture you can have
a chair and then you can have specific
types of chairs so you might have you
know a general uh chair and then you
might inherit from that and have a
couple different styles of chairs like a
computer chair a simple wooden chair or
something like that so uh essentially
you have this front-end controller that
decides which factory is being used and
how the item is being controlled it's
very similar to the factory it's just a
few further abstractions it starts to
get a little more complicated i want to
make a an example here
and i really love using game stuff
because i just feel like it's easy for a
lot of us to wrap our heads around and
understand how to expand so
i've already made a factory two folder
here
and i made a well it's just the cmake
here i've got a main that's ready to
test stuff i also added in a new folder
just called utility and i brought in
rand.h and rand.cpp so if you want some
easy randomization sure we could code it
up from from scrap as we go but if you
want to add in randomization all you can
do is you know if you have a utility
file you can just add it to the cmake
and it'll compile and you can start
using it so that's super cool i think
it's just like utility
slash
rand.h and rand.cbp so that's just
something you can do if you want to have
the file uh once and then use it in
multiple places so in these little sub
projects we want to use it and we can
just add those files and open pile so
super cool i'm going to go ahead and pop
those in because we might use a little
randomization i really like using
randomization i mean it's obviously
necessary for games in general i mean
you can have a static game but then
someone's just going to make a bot to
play it unless you add in some
randomization right all right
um i want to do this with
character classes you know how like in
the demo rpg series i made like rogue
wizard
warrior let's make a factory of like a
base player class and then you know uh
we'll have those abstract into
rogue wizard warrior and based on which
one you get that's going to have
different types of armor and different
weapons and and that that'll basically
be the abstract factory example so i'm
going to make a few classes here and
let's make uh i'm just going to do them
all in header files for the moment so
let's make
character.h and then let's make
weapon.h and then we'll make uh we might
make four of them i don't want to go too
deep but i'm also going to keep these
simplified i'm not going to program them
out so that they're like ready to play i
just want to get them farther enough far
enough too long along that it makes
sense okay so we got character weapon
armor and let's just have a quick uh
ability
and that'll be good enough so we want to
start out each of these with just an
abstract of something so let's go class
ability
and
public void
usability
so it would it would do a thing now this
abilities uh maybe we'll say use class
ability or something like that but we'll
just keep it usability
and the base one is going to do nothing
so let's make it pure virtual so it's
essentially an interface uh ability
interface now uh you could make this a
lot more complicated because you know
abilities very generic you might have
uh some certain thing let's let's do use
attack maybe that'll be that'll be
cooler that
we'll stick with ability
yeah we'll we'll figure it out later all
right so same thing with armor let's
make a base one
class
armor public uh i don't know we'll just
have a
armor sort of a weird one here let's
have a uh
dawn armor
as in like equipped i guess that works
or maybe we could have like uh we'll try
to decide the best way to do this here
now we're not going to make it
functional we'll have we'll just have
dawn armor
that's in equip armor
um the the programmer in me that wants
to make video games wants to make these
like functional and functional enough to
actually uh work in a game but
that's overkill for an example so i'm
i'm gonna fight myself and avoid that
because it's it's gonna drive me crazy
but i'll do it anyway
because uh
i will accidentally make this episode
three hours long if if i just
go off my
instinct all right character
uh let's let's just have a i don't know
we'll return a string on this one let's
see here
yeah we'll have set set the class i
guess
yeah that's fine we might modify this a
bit later to make it make a little more
sense but i'm going to try to just keep
going forward
and the last one weapon
we'll just have a void
set weapon
all right so we got all these little
abstract classes and we need to decide
uh what different options these could
turn into
so
what different characters could we have
what different armors could we have what
different abilities what different
weapons etc so let's have a top end
factory here i'm kind of skipping to the
end just so you can see a bit of the
example and we'll have a uh
like a we'll say an npc factory or yeah
npc factory
that's fine
dot h and in this one we'll have a class
called npc factory and we'll have a boy
and we'll return uh an npc i guess i
guess it would make more sense to be
like
character factory since we have
characters not necessarily npc and then
we could return characters here so it
would be uh we're going to do character
star
character as in you know player npc not
as in
text
and of course we're going to need to
include character because it's going to
not know what it is otherwise
and we'll just have a create
character and
this one will be virtual
and we can uh
basically have some different well
characters being overused i'm just going
to call this create all right so we need
we want our different ones now so let's
uh maybe let's inherit from this let's
go uh rogue
uh yeah rope factory in here from this
character factory
and let's take that function and
overwrite it so uh oh yeah we need to
put virtual import in front of these
virtual okay i'm going to do that real
quick in front of all these i'm skipping
that ahead of time virtual virtual
virtual nice little keyword there
you already caught that good job you're
ahead of curve if not uh very well
doesn't matter a whole lot so we'll have
a create
override keyword here
and this is going to return
um character now this character is pure
abstract so we don't really know what it
is yet but so we basically want to make
the types like there's a rogue
class
warrior
and class
wizard thank you i guess we're not doing
cleric we're just going to do road
warrior wizard uh that's that's going to
be good enough and these are all
inheriting from uh character
uh so i'm just going to copy this down
put it all there
so there's our different options there
and
based on these well we're going to
decide are we going to cascade it are we
going to keep them all like at a single
level because um i'm going to do a
little bit of both i think yeah well
we'll do it uh
we'll we'll do it like this we'll have
you know the characters gonna have some
basic stuff that's kind of required so
let's just give them some quick stats
let's just let's just only go with hp
right now all right for hit points and
that can just default to one so we can
we can just make we just want something
to kind of set in here um let's also
make a string
class
name as in like the characters class
reward or wizard pretty common trope
there
let's include string here um in this way
we can just have something
happen here
for set class so let we call this set
class
void set class maybe better as set class
uh details
or stats or something like that uh
whatever you want to call it let's call
it stats i like stats since uh we've
basically got stats here
details stats whatever either is fine uh
override keyword here
and then we can just go class name
equals rogue
uh and we can go hp whatever we decide
the rogues hp wants to start out as so
six would be fine there's kind of finer
details of doing this in that demo rpg
series where we cascade it more and work
into an actual game but uh we'll just do
a quick example here and let's uh yeah
we'll do all these real quick
class name warrior and since these are
public we're not going to do setters and
getters although technically we could
but i'm kind of going off the dnd base
stats here although it doesn't really
matter just that's how i'm sort of
deciding the numbers
there we go so they all have different
hp
and uh
well no so when we make a character we
got to do this
here
um this should be also public
actually let's do these as private
because i'll show you something cool
here in a second and often how these are
done with c plus all right so these are
private
private but we want constructors here
that are public
so if you make a base rogue
for example it's going to go uh set
class stats
it's just going to call the one down
there so all you can do is construct it
and it's going to do this and do the
thing so i'm just going to do a little
copy paste action get these ones done
and
rename them appropriately and there we
go should set the stuff properly when we
construct them based on all that so
characters are ready to be factoried out
we're good there let's go ahead and
close that one and try not to go back to
it because i think we're good there all
right so now we just want to uh work up
some other stuff but first let's look at
this factory and think about this a
little bit so on a rogue factory when we
call create
and we get a character
um
well we want more than just a character
is the thing we kind of want it all to
be combined at the end so
so maybe
this character here let's see it's going
to return this thing here but let's
uh yeah i like having
let's make a top end uh i'm trying to
think it's it's the
vernacular that's messing me up here not
necessarily because uh yeah characters
character kind of assumes it's a class
you're playing right
uh we just want to have one at the very
top that's like the one you actually get
in the end
because uh i don't know going back to
the furniture example you get all this
furniture
but
how do you use that all you have it like
in a room so you have you end up
creating a room and then you have all
the stuff in it sort of that sort of
thing so we have a character here let's
just make a top end one called player
character
so these are like the playable ones
and this one is just going to have
everything
so we're going to end up creating
layer characters because this is going
to have
uh
let's see i mean i don't know if it's
going to be private or not yet but it's
going to have a character
which is more like the class i don't
know i think this probably makes more
sense as character class yeah let's just
do that that's gonna that's gonna
simplify out the vernacular a lot
because uh there's some sort of some
overlapping terminology here that i'm
trying to avoid to make it less
confusing so this will be the player
character and it's uh they're going to
have a character class
we got to watch out because class
lowercase is a keyword so let's just
throw an underscore at the end of it all
right and we'll do that with all of them
some people do that and we're also going
to have uh like armor
these need to be pointers in this case
because we're going to be using
polymorphism stuff and we're going to
have a weapon
we're going to keep it very simple we're
not going to allow them to swap weapons
or having inventory or anything like
that they're just going to have you know
a warrior's probably going to have like
a great sword or a great axe or some
warrior weapon rogue's going to have a
daggers you know stuff like that just to
differentiate it uh the men kind of make
it simple and what else do we have we
have ability
so essentially we're going to make these
player characters but we're going to use
some abstract uh
factory to determine what kind we want
and i'm going to rename this from npc
factory to just character factory
looks good all right
so character ones ready to be
uh factored out well currently right now
we could make a factory for these
character classes and
and construct those out now we want to
do the same for these armors um
let's go with heavy
uh heavy armor let's call it that
so let's just work all these out real
quick and we're gonna go void
dawn armor
um yeah let's just have armor type here
i'll just make them strings for now
uh you probably want to have them some
more concrete like enums if you have a
limited amount
uh
in them
or you know you know what i'm saying if
you're getting limits to certain types
of armor you probably want to pull from
some dictionary or something not
necessarily have a string string's just
wide open but for sake of example we're
going to keep it as a string
and of course we've got to include
string
just kind of simplifies the example
without having to boilerplate more stuff
all right we need to override this
and we basically want to set the armor
type as heavy
or we could say plate armor yeah that's
fine enough now we could do the same
thing where uh we make this overridden
version private and then we just have a
constructor so when you construct
uh heavy armor
i kind of like this being uh i'm gonna
just
once again like i said earlier i'm
overthinking this i kind of want to make
it so that this is like armor allowed
or armor proficiency but we'll just keep
it tight and i'm just gonna go with
heavy light medium that'll be a little
better
i think so if we go heavy armor you're
allowed heavy armor we're going to give
you a armor type heavy so we'll just
make this constructor here and just fall
dawn armor
that's that's going to be it and then
we'll we'll do a few more of these we'll
go light armor
all this light and we'll put a medium in
the middle of this
medium medium medium
cool so we kind of have that ready to go
uh we have so we've got two things
ability uh you know let's scrap ability
it's kind of getting to be a redundant
example at this point there's already
enough going on basically um
yeah but let's let's do the weapon
though that's fine we've got a set
weapon we want to make sure this is
public or protected protect it's
actually fine yeah we could probably do
all these as protected
at least to some extent
i'm going to leave the things we set
public but i'm gonna make this one
protected that way no one else can call
it further
yeah that's fine it's fine that should
be good
we could do special stuff where uh we if
you don't want people to construct these
warriors we could end up making
this private as well these constructors
and then just put a friend class for the
factory like
friend class
uh
what character factory yeah character
factory that way only the character
factory can make these
so that'd be kind of a cool thing i
think we gotta go well i don't know if
we actually need to include it here but
but let's let's do that let's let's add
in a little additional layer of control
um alright these are
if these are private we can just get rid
of you know class is default to private
so we can get rid of all this stuff but
we want it to just be private and we can
just put friend class i believe we can
just put it in the character class here
now we got to be careful about the
private on this one because uh
inheritance
they're not going to have access to it
so let's let's make it like this yeah
that'll be fine formatting let's try
that out so i'm curious i don't actually
know if this is going to work so i think
if i do the character class on the
interface or the friend class on the
interface is it going to allow me to
access the private stuff down here
we're going to find out we might have
some errors if so clean it up but a
little trial and error here i just want
to see and sometimes you got to do that
kind of stuff because it's it's fun so
we'll do the same thing here
that public this one protected and let's
also go friend class
character factory
and we'll leave all these
private so we can just get rid of all
these cool and then same thing is
probably going to happen for weapon
you can play around with these and do
them as you want of course to some
extent for we got rid of ability i'm
kind of jumping around a little bit here
our player character of course is going
to need
armor it's going to need
uh character class
yeah i gotta rename this uh this one the
character class
character class and uh i think that's
about it
uh we're also going to have weapon still
a little more boilerplate this does take
a little more boilerplate but once it's
all set up it can be very nice because
it allows the client to not know about
the behind-the-scenes code and just
create what they want so that's that's
where it gets kind of cool
and
yeah it just allows well it's an
abstract factory that's that's that's
the way it goes
um
because you know from the client end
eventually you'll be able to use a
single line of code and get everything
together as you want rather than having
to call a bunch of different things it's
kind of the point here that we're
building towards
all right we've got set weapon
let's just make public uh we'll make it
we'll use string again for to simplify
this whole thing and we'll just call it
weapon type it could default to time to
find
but that's fine this is good all right
we need to include string here
so now let's make some of these uh what
types of weapons let's let's go off the
dnd theme where they have kind of
marshall
simple i don't know what else they have
i don't know we'll make up a third one
so class martial
weapon public
weapon
and uh we'll do once again
friends class might be messing this up a
little bit but we'll correct it if so
and then we just want to have that
constructor marshall weapon
we want to have it called that weapon
and we want to override the set weapon
override keyword is actually optional
but
you should always put it there because
if you don't put it there and you're
accidentally not overwriting it'll throw
an error so it's just something to make
your life a little easier but if we left
it off it would be it would be fine it's
just that if we actually made this an
integer and forgot to override we would
think we were overwriting it but we're
not so you just have to be a lot more
careful an override keyword just will
throw an error if you've messed up the
override so that's really all it does
actually
it doesn't force any override or
anything like that as far as i know
so we're just gonna go
weapon type
equals marshall and marshall assumes all
the standard warrior weapons basically
like you know the big heavy axes and
swords and stuff like that
and we'll make a few more of these um
maybe we'll just make simple
i want to have at least one more
simple weapons would be like you know
utensils basic dagger i think everyone
can figure out how to use that it's
pretty simple
uh stuff like that and then we'll have a
last one called like uh i don't know
maybe magical i don't know it's fine
there's probably a better one to put but
there we go because we could assume that
like the wizard knows how to use magical
weapons or something like that no
magical's a weird example let's find
something else
maybe we'll just say common i don't know
sure
i don't know that's probably not the
best name for a uh weapon type but you
get the point i'm trying to make a
cascade here it would go like marshall
common simple if you know how to use
marshall you know how to use common
simple if you know how to use common you
know how to use simple as well et cetera
if you know how to use simple you
probably are not good with you know
trying to make a little scale thing like
that but you know it's not actually
going to be fully programmed in but just
for sake of it making a little bit of
sense
is the point
all right so now we got a character
factor we got a rogue we want to make a
rogue uh what is the rogue gonna do
so
um
the rogue well
for creating a rogue and returning a uh
what is a player character here
player character here
we want to call this create method and
this create is going to set everything
for this player character which are all
three of these so maybe we need to we
probably need to go for in the class in
here too
bring
class
you can do it without the friend if you
use just public constructors um
so either would probably work
fine here
uh character
and also i'm sort of skipping over some
of these factories and just using
constructors as i kind of mentioned like
for example uh each of these character
classes yeah we got a character class
here but we should have also a like a
rogue factory right instead we're just
going to go
new rogue basically
because that will call this constructor
assuming we're allowed
um based on this friend class i don't
know if i don't know if it inherits
these friend classes so i guess we'll
see i'm going to put it
i don't know we'll play around with it
and see what kind of errors we get we'll
learn a thing or two all right friend
class character factory
so we get a player character
uh we can only set these based on
i'm probably making this more
complicated by doing all this public
private stuff like i could we could just
use structs and ignore all of that if
we're
making it more simple
all right but let's let's just keep
going nonetheless i've kind of covered
all those little scenarios where i'm i'm
maybe skipping a few parts of additional
factories but it really depends on how
complicated you're going to get because
uh we're doing a very simple example so
you might want an actual rogue factory
that sets more specific rogue stuff but
the constructor is going to be good for
now so if you make a rogue factory and
you just call create
it should set your player character ever
just as expected so let's make a player
character and we'll just call this the
return character or maybe the
constructed character or whatever it's
the one we're going to return
constructed
uh character and also quick note here uh
you can see we are returning a pointer
which means we're returning access to a
memory so these factories assume that
you must clean up your own memory uh if
they're not managing the memory
so fyi so in our main later when we
create it we're also going to have to
destroy it so just a quick note on that
i'm probably going to skip over a lot of
that and leave the memory leaks in just
for sake of not making it any more
confusing than it probably already is
all right so this constructed character
we want to set it all up basically we
want to set all these things we could
say that the constructed character i'm
just going to call it cc so i don't have
to type as much uh cc equals new
player character
ah i am skipping a step okay yeah let's
let's back up a little bit uh we want
this front end character factory to be
the the final top-end one that calls the
right factories so actually this rogue
factory
would be better in the rogue area
okay or rather okay so this says robe
factory but let's make it uh
trying to think how to do this without
being too complicated i think
essentially what i'm doing here is i'm
making this half builder method
accidentally so
i'll straighten that out all right so
what we're doing wrong here is
essentially we're abstracting or we're
making one factory kind of construct
everything you're supposed to have like
a bunch of different factories which
makes sense i guess because if you just
want one of something and you don't want
the rest uh i don't know abstract
factories basically get really
complicated after a while is the point
of getting to
and uh that's pretty normal so we have
like this player character that uses the
player or the character factory and the
character factor is going to make all
the stuff for the player character but
also uh we could have you know an armor
factory to to make the right types of
armor which we should do if we're doing
a proper example but instead i think
we're just gonna use these constructors
because it's so simple but it'd be just
like the first episode where we make a
factory for each of these like a medium
armor factory heavy armor factor factory
and that would make more sense if these
had more options other than just uh the
uh basic types so we're going to kind of
skip over that a little bit just to to
make it a little more simple
so all right so let's just make this
player character so we'll make a player
character
and we need the different parts of it
let's see where's your character class
armor weapon all right class
equals new and then we want what type of
class so
uh let's say this one's a rogue for
example but you don't necessarily know
what type you're creating until you have
some sort of thing in this create so we
need to pass in something that says what
we want to create and what we can do is
we can use a string and we can just call
it uh class type
now string is kind of a bad example
because you can't switch on it it'd be
better to have an enum with all the
available classes or something like that
for c plus plus in general but uh
instead we're going to just go if uh
class type equals
uh
rogue
now we probably also want to do some
additional stuff and like make sure it's
all the right case or just make
everything lower case and go from there
but uh this will work for now so if they
say if the class type is rogue then
we're going to instantiate all this
rogue stuff like so
player character
uh what else do we have
armor
equals new
all right ropes use medium armor
so we construct some medium armor
and then what else we have we have
weapon uh weapon
equals new it'd probably be better as a
weapon proficiency based on the way we
did it but whatever we'll say they can
use uh
a common weapon or something let's take
a quick look at those yeah
weapon type comment all right so back to
our character effect and there we go and
then we would just return this player
character
and you can probably see how the rest of
this is going to go oops it should all
be uh
and uh basically we just want some other
statements here
probably else if
else if warrior do the warrior stuff
heavy armor warriors uh marshall weapon
it'd be better so this is these news
right here these could all be little
individual factories but essentially
we're just using constructors because
they're so simple hopefully that doesn't
take away from this particular pattern
but you're kind of seeing the point of
we have a top level
factory that abstracts the other
factories based on what we want to
create so this one is the only one
that the client is going to use
everything else is going to be hidden
and all they're going to get is a proper
rogue warrior
wizard or whatever it may be
so a wizard here
new wizard
oops
actually file button let's cancel that
it allows me to
there we go and they're going to use
light armor
and
a simple weapon
so that's essentially the main point
here
and what if the the fail case
well we can just return null i guess you
could you could throw something if you
want
but
since this returns a pointer
see character factory
character
there we go so we don't really you know
we're kind of doing this in a way where
we don't really need this public
interface here actually uh because it's
not really doing a whole lot
but uh yeah so well let's just get rid
of this we don't really need it in our
example but you might and yours
depending on what you're doing
all right so i'm gonna do a little
cleanup here
i'll just make this an else case for the
return null
and i'm expecting some compiler errors
so we'll see if that happens now also if
you don't want people to make a bunch of
different character classes and you only
need one for your program you can also
throw the singleton pattern on this now
we can make this a singleton class by
just making all this static like so
and that will do do it there
that way we don't have to worry about
the instance and stuff
let's go ahead and hit compile and see
if this actually works uh let's go to
our main let's include
uh character
factory
which should give us everything we need
because it has character
player character
uh oh we don't have character anymore
player character which has armor
character class weapon yeah that should
that should include everything we need i
forgot to put pragma once at the top of
all these we'll do that real quick
all the headers
just
just to stop some of the double include
problems
i think i'm going to retroactively go
back to these old ones see i put
fragment now but i don't think i did in
the episodes so just make sure sure you
always have that pragma once at the top
of all those okay cool
save and let's make sure our cmake is
correct and it's added all our classes
looks like it has we're not using any of
this rand but uh so i'm going to delete
all that all right let's let's see make
do its thing we're going to hit our
build and see what happens here we got a
little bit of a redefinition
well this should just now be character
factory uh based on the way we did it
you're not not going to get too
complicated there these should be equals
equals very important otherwise we're
going to be
setting them and also we should return
the class that we're creating here so
not their character but you know cc
which is what we named our player
character
class cc i don't know
let's see it looks like these are not
very happy probably because they're
private and this character factory
should have access to him oh we don't
need the right keyword here either
but let's let's just see what error it
gives us so i don't think that friend
class is allowing us to do that yeah
private member so even though the
character factory
is a friend here it looks like it
doesn't abstract it down further so
the easiest way to do this would just be
to make these public
constructors
since it defaults to
private i'm going to leave the private
stuff at the top
that way we only have to type
a little bit not too much
but yeah i just wanted to experiment
with that so we'll have a quick look at
this one yeah we'll get rid of these
just make all these constructors public
so it'd probably be better here
if we're going a little bit further to
actually make proper factories for these
and make the friend class of each of
these the factory uh for the different
armors and uh weapons and stuff but you
can kind of see the point and i'm
probably probably going far enough
fix up these real quick
uh this one actually needs to we didn't
make a constructor on this marshall
weapon
at all so
that's just gonna call set weapon
all sorts of little tricks you can do
which is kind of the point of design
patterns are essentially little tricks
you can do
to
simplify your code base a little bit and
it might not look more simple right now
but the reason it's more simple is
because uh one of the big reasons anyway
is maintenance costs so if we want to
change yeah rather than having to change
a bunch of things in the code say for
example you don't like this common
weapon that says weapon type to come and
you just want to change it to uh
something else you only have to change
it in one part of the code and it
cascades everywhere else and the client
end
which they're only going to have that's
they're going to have access to the
factory basically so this is the only
thing they would they would see they
won't see this back end being changed
you won't need to change the interface
it'll all stay the same let's say play
again see if we have any more errors we
probably will but it looks like uh well
hold on we had one thing i thought
no it seems okay i think one of these
keywords is redundant i think this one
here it's not necessary okay but it
seems to compile we haven't put any test
code in here but let's go ahead and do
it let's just say we want a new player
character
uh we'll call him bob
bob
and we
want bob to be i guess we need to be a
pointer here
um
we can decide
based on this player character factory
uh
it'll be character factory now since
this is a static class you just call
create to pass it what we want to be
making bob's a robe
that's all we need to do let's create a
robe
and that's going to take care of the
rest let's just just quick see outs make
sure bob seems uh correct all this stuff
is actually
private
class right character class player
character yeah these are all private so
uh let's actually make
i don't know let's just make some quick
getters
so we can do uh
they're all strings i think yeah so we
can just make them quickly
get uh
class
return
class dot class name
and we could put more in here
see what doesn't like about this oh it's
because well it's a pointer so uh class
could be null that could be very
dangerous uh so we probably actually
want to go something like if
if class then return class name
that way we're not running into some
null pointer issues
it still seems to be complaining a
little bit
oh it's just this it's not a function
all right that wasn't the reason it was
complaining but that would be a problem
so
it is very valid to check first and
maybe we want an else case of just
return uh not
set right we can do that for all these
let's do real quick
uh well we can do get hp as well
which works off the class so if
class is set uh return
hp is an integer so we can just do this
as an image real quick and i'll just fly
through these and then i'll come back to
you guys as soon as i'm done so if class
do negative one is the error case for hp
is not set
and we can do the rest here
once again i think it's worth repeating
strings are probably terrible in this
case for most of this stuff if you're
making a real program
so keep that in mind
but this one we want to make sure the
armor is set
and we'll continue on
make sure the weapon is set
and i think that's everything yeah okay
there that'll give us a little access to
this uh we probably also want to do a
quick check on bob here before we see
out all this stuff
just to make sure we don't get any
strange errors
hit bob see out uh we'll just do some
some lines of uh
bob
uh
see what do we have access to let's look
at our player character now we have all
these get get stuff okay
so that's what we have to use
get
class
says it's inaccessible
why isn't it accessible let's take a
quick look uh we forgot to put public at
the top of this so to bolt it to private
that's a thing all right and we'll just
put like a new line character at the end
of each of these
since it's a single character we can use
single quotes it looks like two
characters but this actually just turns
into a new line character that's just
how you write it code um i should
probably make this bigger i may have
overlooked that way earlier
but uh we'll just continue on with this
with uh get hp
and so on
get armor
get weapon
maybe we'll call this guy up
bob the rogue okay so now if we hit play
here if this thing created the road
correctly we should see yeah rogue
medium armor common weapons obviously
there's a little
overlooking a few other things here such
as we're not really saying what these
are
so it would make a little sense to go uh
last name you know something like this
basically
the way we
were talking about
using more like weapons and armor
efficiency but whatever you get the
point will hit play here there we go
uh we could say more even you know we
could there could be more stuff we could
expand on this pretty easily you know
we'll probably want names and all sorts
of stuff but let's just make another
quick example and make a player
character uh chet
the warrior
and we'll do the same same thing
character factory
uh create
warrior
so that should return as a warrior let's
copy down this line line of code here
open and make sure this pointer
and also when we're done with something
we need to make sure we delete them and
clean up the memory
i said i might not do that but
we are done with bob you're not using
them anymore you got to delete them
somewhere let's uh clean all this up
chat chat chat chat
chat you could have a manager system
since we're using a single pen where you
keep track of what's been instantiated
and delete them automatically and stuff
like that but we're not going to worry
about that too much there's also still
some memory leaks in here i believe
because uh let's see here uh these uh
what is it yeah it'd be these these are
still going to leak memory because even
if we delete our player character these
pointers also need deleted so we
probably want to do something like just
make a destructor or player character
here that goes uh
basically calls delete on all of these
hip
glass
delete
glass
hip armor delete
there this will take care of uh
abstracting the rest of it that way we
need to
pull
week manually on everything within this
class
they're not null they'll be deleted when
we delete the player character
so pretty straightforward there and we
want to do that anywhere else for
pointers of course just manage them
correctly but uh it's a little bit
beyond the scope of this particular
pattern but it's just you know good
practice
all right
yeah so we make a rogue we make a
warrior we could of course make the
wizard too let's just make sure this
runs correctly looks good we got our
rope we got our warrior they seem to be
getting the right stuff you can kind of
now see that point of the abstract
factory uh you know the client and all
they get is this character factory
create where they can pass in some
details about how they want it created
and it just kind of automatically
creates the right thing so that's that's
really the big point here and i think
i've probably gone on long enough
there's probably more i could say this
you know you can get
these get complicated that's that's kind
of the downside to the abstract factory
is it gets complicated and the upside is
you only expose a very small thing such
as this create method and it does all
sorts of stuff on the back end so
from the back in perspective
it's very easy to manage stuff for
example we're we're not happy with the
way warrior works anymore maybe maybe
our maybe wizards or something you know
something needs to change we can just
change it right in this create method
only or if we can leave these the same
even if they're fine and go deeper into
stuff that they're not supposed that the
client is not supposed to access and
change these uh like i was saying
earlier well that's gonna do it for this
episode let me know what you think of
the abstract uh pattern and leave your
comments down below if you have any and
i'll see you in the next one
[Music]
[Music]
you